l'officialisation était attendue depuis
plusieurs semaines elle est intervenue
ce lundi 9 janvier au ministère des
affaires étrangères à paris
l'open de france organisé tous les ans
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines va être désormais sponsorisé
pendant cinq ans par le groupe chinois à
chênée spécialisée dans le transport
aérien à la dotation de la compétition
va être triplés elle va atteindre 6,6
millions d'euros ce qui en fera l'un des
tournois les plus prestigieux en europe
au niveau des tournois en europe et en
sommet à nouveau plutôt en fanfare en
lumière et ça donne du coup un éclairage
nouveau plat aujourd'hui avec tout ce
que nous avons appris bien on s'aperçoit
que non seulement nous avons un nouveau
sponsor non seulement c'est un sponsor
important mais surtout nous entrons dans
une nouvelle dimension
mais là cette fois ça nous permet de
faire partie des grands tournois
européens et surtout de nous de nous
positionner carrément au niveau mondial
conséquence directe ce nouveau
partenariat va attirer les journalistes
du monde entier surtout des joueurs de
renommée internationale à partir de
cette année les irlandais harrington et
laurie et le français alexandre lévy ont
déjà annoncé leur participation
ça arrive aussi en même temps que la
ryder cup 2018 donc on va parler de plus
en plus du golf en france et c'est sûr
que nous jeunes joueurs on essaye
d'amener notre petite touche de jeunesse
pour que les gens s'intéressent de plus
en plus et essaye de on essaye aussi de
démocratiser un peu ce sport pour voir
ces stars du golf en action il faudra
être patient la 101e édition de l'open
de france est programmée du 29 juin au 2
juillet au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines